Transcription: Manon Armenoult
Relecteur: eric vautier
Kakistocratie.
Ka-kis-to-cra-tie.
Mais quel mot bizarre !
Que peut-il désigner ?
Une maladie psychique ?
Une démonstration mathématique ?
Une contrée bizarre ?
L’élevage des kakis ?
Rien de tout cela.
La kakistocratie,
comme beaucoup de mots savants,
est forgée sur deux mots grecs :
Kakistos :
« les pires ».
Kratos :
« le gouvernement ».
La kakistocratie,
c’est « le gouvernement par les pires ».
Le règne des médiocres.
Le pouvoir des incompétents.
Ça pourrait être le titre
d’un thriller ou d’une sombre fiction
et en fait, c’est une situation
que vous rencontrez peut-être
tous les jours.
Vous êtes-vous posé
la question récemment ?
« Comment mon manager, mon boss, mon PDG
est-il arrivé à ce poste
alors qu’il est
complètement incompétent ? »
Ou autre formule :
« Comment ce PDG, ce boss
est-il encore en poste après des années
alors qu’il est nul
et que tout le monde le sait ? »
Bienvenue en kakistocratie !
Quand j’ai commencé à évoquer
ce concept sur les réseaux sociaux,
j’ai eu des centaines de messages.
Et ça continue.
Il y avait des gens qui me remerciaient
d’avoir posé un mot,
même compliqué,
sur une situation complexe
qu’ils vivaient,
qu’ils n’arrivaient pas à décrypter.
Il y avait aussi, et il y a toujours,
des centaines de messages
de gens qui m’exprimaient leur souffrance
car ce n’est pas simple
de travailler en kakistocratie.
Vous découvrez quoi ?
Que l’incompétence, que la médiocrité
ont de la valeur
alors que depuis tout petit,
on vous dit quoi ?
« Il faut bien travailler à l’école
pour avoir un diplôme. »
« Il faut être compétent
pour être recruté. »
« Il faut être le meilleur
pour être promu. »
En kakistocratie,
toutes ces valeurs qui forgeaient
votre existence -
mérite, reconnaissance, compétence -
explosent, disparaissent.
Il y a de quoi être perturbé.
Au quotidien, ce n’est pas simple
d’avoir un manager incompétent.
Il faut faire à sa place.
Il faut aussi gérer un sentiment
de frustration et d’injustice
car on a travaillé dur, nous,
pour en arriver là.
On peut aussi ressentir
de la honte pour son organisation.
Et cela peut aller jusqu’à
la perte d’estime de soi.
Donc c’est bien de poser un mot
sur un phénomène,
mais ça ne suffit pas.
Il faut comprendre le pourquoi
et le comment de la kakistocratie.
Ça vous intéresse ?
Public : Oui !
Je vais vous livrer
deux niveaux d’explication :
l’un plus au niveau des individus
et l’autre plus au niveau des systèmes
car il y a des systèmes organisés
de kakistocratie.
Au niveau des individus,
il y a trois comportements
que l’on rencontre classiquement.
Vous les connaissez.
Le premier rejoint ce qu’on appelle
le principe de Peter.
Peter a dit
que plus on monte dans la hiérarchie,
plus on rencontre son incompétence.
Au début, on est très compétent puis
moins compétent puis de moins en moins.
Et dans tous ces dispositifs
de promotion à l’ancienneté,
si on ne sait pas dire non,
on se retrouve, en situation de pouvoir,
incompétent pour sa fonction.
Deuxième situation,
c’est ce qu’on peut appeler
le piège de la compétence.
Vous êtes chef de service
et vous avez dans votre équipe
quelqu’un d’hyper-compétent,
un expert ou une experte.
Grâce à lui ou elle,
la boutique tourne, tout marche.
Les autres, c’est moins bien.
Qu’est-ce que vous faites ?
Eh bien, vous cherchez à le garder.
Vous allez éviter de le perdre
parce que ce serait
trop long, trop compliqué.
Et au contraire,
vous allez plutôt surnoter,
faire partir les moins compétents
qui vont aller tranquillement
vers des promotions.
Troisième comportement kakistocrate,
c’est tout simplement
la peur de la compétence.
Vous n'êtes pas très compétent.
On vous demande de recruter des talents.
Super !
Qu’est-ce qui va se passer ?
Ils risquent de vous mettre
devant votre incompétence,
et pire,
de prendre votre place.
Donc il vaut peut-être mieux
recruter des moins compétents
pour continuer à les dominer et à briller.
Je passe au système.
Il y a trois grands leviers
de la kakistocratie.
Le premier, c'est la dette.
J’illustre.
Vous recrutez un compétent
ou une compétente.
Normal, il ne vous doit rien.
Au contraire, il va contribuer
à l’organisation, à l’entreprise.
Et vous recrutez quelqu’un qui n’est pas
assez compétent pour le poste.
Il vous doit quelque chose.
Il vous est redevable
et il le sera toute sa carrière.
C’est comme ça que se construisent
les mandarinats universitaires.
Un autre levier
des systèmes kakistocrates,
c’est la configuration clanique.
Vous connaissez aussi.
Ces entreprises où ce qui est
le plus important,
c’est d’embaucher son frère,
sa sœur, son oncle, son cousin.
Jusqu'à aller au syndrome
du fils du patron.
Parce que le clan qui se moque
de la compétence et de la performance,
son seul objectif, c’est de se perpétuer.
On cite la mafia comme illustration.
Le dernier mécanisme, c’est le système,
la négation de la personne
au profit du système.
« Je me moque que tu sois
compétent ou incompétent,
c’est moi qui décide qui sera promu
et qui ne le sera pas. »
On retrouve ces configurations
dans des systèmes totalitaires
où des partis politiques
régissent la vie des gens.
Après, tout s’entrecroise et s’entremêle.
Il y a des gens qui ont
des comportements kakistocrates
et d’autres qui sont dans des systèmes.
Mais au centre, on voit bien que
la question qui se pose, c’est la loyauté.
Posez-vous la question :
est-ce que vous êtes loyal
à vous et à votre carrière ?
Ou est-ce que vous êtes
loyal au bien commun,
qui est une entreprise, une association,
une administration ?
La promotion pour bons et loyaux services.
Service à qui ? À quoi ?
On sent bien que la kakistocratie,
c’est l’antithèse du management
qui, par définition,
aide les gens à se développer,
à s’épanouir, à grandir en compétences.
Alors comment chacun à son niveau,
au vôtre,
peut-il avancer sur ce sujet ?
Je vous propose quatre étapes.
La première, c'est de faire un diagnostic.
Est-ce que, réfléchissez, vous avez
dans votre entourage professionnel
repéré ces signaux dont je parle ?
Si oui, est-ce que vous adhérez ?
Il y a peut-être parmi vous
des kakistocrates heureux,
des kakistocrates assumés,
des kakistocrates qui s’ignorent.
Si ce n’est pas le cas,
eh bien, il faut du courage.
Aurez-vous le courage
de dénoncer ces procédés ?
Car vous avez bien compris que
si vous vous attaquez à la kakistocratie,
vous vous attaquez aux gens
qui ont le pouvoir
et qui n’ont pas envie de le laisser.
Et puis, dernière étape,
est-ce qu’à votre niveau
vous pouvez faire quelque chose ?
Que l’acteur en vous
fasse bouger le système.
Par exemple, recruter des gens
qui sont talentueux dans votre service
alors que ce n’est pas du tout
la pratique dans l’organisation.
C'est compliqué de faire
bouger les lignes seul.
Il y a trois pistes
pour faire évoluer les choses.
Trois pistes intéressantes
pour sortir de la kakistocratie.
La première, c’est de recruter des femmes.
(Applaudissements)
Pas parce qu’elles sont plus vertueuses,
mais parce qu’elles ont
un rapport à la légitimité, au pouvoir
et à la compétence différent des hommes.
Statistiquement.
Je vous donne un exemple très drôle.
En 2011, une loi, Copé-Zimmermann,
exige la parité dans les conseils
d’administration des entreprises.
Il n’y a que des hommes
donc on va chercher des femmes.
Des femmes puissantes.
Des femmes de direction.
Des femmes intellectuellement équipées.
Et elles disent : « Ah oui, oui,
moi je suis très intéressée
mais ne me sens pas compétente pour
être dans un conseil d’administration.
Ça s’apprend.
Je voudrais une formation. »
Donc on fait des formations
pour ces femmes.
Et qui on voit arriver
dans ces formations ?
Ces messieurs
qui depuis des années siégeaient
dans les conseils d’administration
sans se poser la question
de la compétence.
Donc recruter des femmes,
c’est challenger l’incompétence.
Deuxième piste très intéressante
et très paradoxale,
c’est de valoriser l’incompétence.
On part de loin.
Dès l’école maternelle ou du CP,
on vous fait valoir qu’une erreur,
c’est une faute.
Qu’il vaut mieux camoufler ses échecs.
Qu’être incompétent,
c’est montrer sa vulnérabilité.
Et si on faisait de l’incompétence,
de l’échec, de l’erreur,
quelque chose d’apprenant
pour avancer.
Mandela disait :
« Quelquefois on gagne,
et quelquefois on apprend. »
Se mettre dans
cette situation d’apprentissage,
c’est une façon de
lutter contre la kakistocratie.
Et la troisième piste, c’est le
« name and shame » des Anglo-Saxons.
C’est-à-dire pointer du doigt
ces pratiques, les dénoncer.
Pour que plus personne n’ait envie
de rejoindre ces organisations,
qu’on ait plutôt envie de les quitter.
On est devant des situations complexes.
Churchill disait : « Il ne faut jamais
gaspiller une bonne crise. »
Je pense qu’en matière de crise,
nous avons été servis depuis deux ans.
Il faut en faire quelque chose.
Nous savons maintenant de quel
management nous avons envie.
Nous avons envie
d’un management bienveillant,
d’un management éthique,
d’un management équitable,
d’un management
qui reconnaît les personnes,
qui reconnaît leurs compétences,
qui reconnaît leur mérite, leurs efforts.
Il faut avancer.
Il faut avancer et régénérer
nos modalités de management.
Comme je l’ai dit, c’est complexe,
cela demande beaucoup de courage.
C’est vrai que les kakistocraties de
façon consubstantielle se reproduisent.
Mais ce que je vous dis aussi,
c’est qu’elles ne sont pas une fatalité.
Nous pouvons, si nous le voulons,
vous pouvez, si vous le voulez,
briser les chaînes.
Et ça, j’espère vous en avoir
donné l’envie et l’énergie.
(Applaudissements)
Merci.